[Music]
let's go to katie in colorado springs to
kick off this hour hi katie how are you
hi dave doing well how are you great how
can we help
well um we're baby step seven um
and my son who's 17 just about 18 now
has been racing go-karts for a couple of
years and
he's ready to move up from basically
from a state level to
more of a regional level basically west
of the mississippi
and i'm having a little trouble deciding
what's a reasonable amount
to budget for that
okay
so um
where does this lead
when he's done
ultimately i think i don't know any 57
year old go-kart racers
yeah um i mean he understands that when
he's
done with college you know out doing his
own thing that it's it's going to be
something that if he wants to continue
with that he will have to fund it
himself
um does he win prize money
are you just supporting a hobby trophy
yeah it's it's pretty much a hobby uh he
took a championship in the state league
last year
so he's
basically he's giving me
i don't know how this works do you move
up from this to be to driving nascar
uh no just carting um
well the gold cards if there are adult
leagues um i know i know that but i'm
just saying that yeah okay because some
hobbies actually lead into stuff i'll
give an example okay my my son played
ice hockey i played ice hockey and i
coached my son playing ice hockey and we
had the opportunity to spend a bazillion
dollars to put him on the travel team
however we knew that him having my dna
meant he was not going to be in the nhl
okay
and so this is not going anywhere except
it is recreational sports for fun
and so how much you of course think he's
going to be an f1 driver someday but no
he's it's
it's a hobby uh he is very very good at
it but i i don't see him ever
going into that that's kind of that's
part of what goes into the equation is
are we going somewhere with this
that becomes a career
i mean if you've got a kid that's going
to be in the nhl and you want to spend a
billion dollars on travel team and
individual coaching and everything else
that's a different thing than kid
playing rec league we were playing rec
league and you know we just needed to
admit that and budget accordingly so
that's what i was asking about is that
kind of a thing and then the other thing
i guess is as a percentage of your world
or of your net worth what's your net
worth
uh net worth we're probably just under a
million okay and what are we spending on
this hobby
this year to do all of the races that my
husband would like him to be doing uh
we're looking at thirty to forty
thousand dollars that's the magic
our income is about 165. yeah so that
that man i was
you you threw me an underhand softball
pitch here so i've seen this with
baseball kids and i was a baseball kid
that turns into rec league turns into
travel team turns into for a half a
million dollars like dave was talking
about but what i often find is kids like
playing with other kids it's the moms
and the dads who have some sort of
identity investment in this
so when you say and that's a big part of
it yeah i think my husband is living
vicariously through our side there you
go
there you go and so there's something
beneath your question here are you
looking for two guys to give you
permission to put the brakes on
something that's out of control
oh yeah no pun intended horrible
honestly i i think i'm more looking for
permission to to let it happen i mean
where
you know dave always talks about the
security gland um
i grew up
very lower middle class and i am a
hoarder i when i get cash in the savings
account i don't like to let go of it
and um i guess
okay so here here's the thing i guess
maybe kind of talk myself
financially this is not going to
bankrupt you you're going to be fine
this is not killing you okay it's not
it's not i'm not aghast at what you're
spending 40 grand based on your income
and based on the fact you have a million
dollars okay okay and your baby steps
seven they're 100 out of debt house and
everything okay and um i i but what does
bother me is motivation and i don't hear
uh
good motivation down under here and i
think that might also be disturbing you
and you're trying to blame yourself
being cheap
on your disturbance and maybe it's not
maybe it's not you're being cheap maybe
you see that there's
this is not going
it's it's out of it's gotten it was a
fun thing that got out of control right
again and dad got some self-esteem out
of it yeah and i'm wondering if mom
feels like she's my dad trying to
protect how much my husband wants him to
race this year that's right yeah that's
a that's a telling line right there
so financially you're probably okay i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna give you
permission to
stop everything based on just the money
in your situation you probably have the
money but there's other stuff going on
here and the money's talking to you you
need to listen to it